what is the next AI generated prompt
guards let me know
the weirdest food combinations people
would actually enjoy roast sandwiches
sandwiches sandwiches it's kind of
similar to the last thing I guess but uh
food combination we have in there of
curiosity we only have one more of this
actually weird food combinations
um mayo and anything it's pretty good
Japanese Mayo Japanese Mayo just give me
Japanese mayo man keep your mouth you
could just put that with anything the
more I like Mayo I don't know why
as a kid I remember hating mayonnaise I
used to think it was disgusting it
looked it looked vile as well well but
but I mean UK Mayo is yeah I mean
Western Mayo is like different we have
like the widest shade of white mayo and
it's like isn't it like a little bit
more watery as well yeah yeah I never
liked that yeah that was gross [__]
[__] yeah Japanese Mayo all the way this
is creamy what about adding cheese to
what what does cheese not work with Okay
let them cook huh let them cook whatever
audience suggests what it's cheese I
work with because because I I asked this
because growing up okay well there was a
big separation for me between like let's
say Western food and Asian Cuisine and
the concept of like adding cheese to
like a lot of like Thai Cuisine and like
Asian Cuisine I was just like I don't
see it happening yeah but then but then
I discovered Korean cuisine that does
that and I'm like oh maybe this can work
maybe maybe we need to like maybe we
need to think about this a bit more yeah
you know because like same was like like
a crutch for food I think because like
not not for at least for foods that are
bad can be made
more edible with cheese on them because
cheese is so good and overpowering
anything else it's right right and I
find that normally it's at least in in
Japan and stuff the cheaper the food the
more chance that we choose involved yeah
that's just because they're like all
right let's let's put some cheese to
mask this it'll be like I don't know
what will they have cheese with on here
a lot of the time like Asian food I
don't really want cheese with it okay
how do we feel about cheese and rice
that's a little scary okay what can you
give me an example of food like just a
bed of rice or some [__] cheese
honestly I've never tried it but I've
tried it it could be good I mean yeah
because I mean mayo and rice is nice so
that mayo and cheese are not the same
things yeah I don't know what I'm saying
yeah because because I I was just like
cheese and rice that wouldn't that would
never work no it does work yeah then and
then I there I tried it a few in a few
places in Japan I'm like okay this this
is like it's like it's like the pasta of
Asia cheese and carbs
carbs and cheese go like hand in hand
yeah yeah I don't [__] with people when
they put like nacho cheese on like
broccoli or something I've had that a
few times in Japan broccoli yeah it'll
be like cheese broccoli and then I order
it and it's like nacho cheese like the
canned natural yeah
[__] does that go well with you know I
would argue nothing I will accept it
with oh really I put mayonnaise on it uh
wait sorry no no we're talking about
nachos
that's not food I'm like that that
barely goes with nachos give me real
cheese with nachos is there any point
where I would choose that [__] fake
cheese over the blue cheese what I'm
trying to think is there anything cheese
doesn't go well with is cheese just the
hacked I was gonna say cake but we
literally have cheesecake we literally
have cheesecake [__] uh his cheese just
that op no cheese is very open I'm just
like thinking that it's just fat and
carbs so yeah that's the stuff it makes
it way more unhealthy there's got to be
like some dish or like food item where
if you put it with cheese it becomes
immediately disgusting
well dude I don't know because you can
get like brata and soft fruit you're
right yeah and you get like fondue as
well yes you dip like you dip like this
I think it's cheese is so versatile
generally like there's there's so many
different flavors you can have with it
yeah I think there's a there's a cheese
for everything unfortunately it's
unfortunate I think there is I think
there's a cheese factory okay this is
cheesy quality this is one this is one
thing I don't get where I've been to
like some let's say high-class
restaurants right okay and they have a
cheese course which comes after the main
course and I think the French do this a
lot uh whether you have cheese is like a
dessert yeah I didn't get that I I do
not get that get it because normally
you're just drinking at that point right
so it's more of like a snacking thing
and it's not like a very heavy
um sweet like taste it's like you can
have a little bite savoriness but it is
a lot I really miss it it's it's a I
don't know how people can handle it
because by the time I finish the main
course I'm like I'm [__] done and
they're like oh we have another cheese
course and I'm like What's you want me
to eat Savory stuff after this I'm
[__] dying man I mean like I I barely
get the dessert after a course anyway
because I'm as you said like I want to
be full with the main course right so I
don't have space for anything else but
like sometimes I've been tempted to be
like yeah I'll take a little nibble some
cheese
but the problem is is that a lot of
those like cheese boards is like it's
like six or seven pieces of different
cheese so it's just like that's just
like I was expecting maybe two you know
yeah it's just too much well shouldn't
work
good
that sweet sweet and savory can work but
it's it's hard to do it's it's hard to
do I think okay I'm not a fan of like
red bean things being like like kidney
beans no no like the red bean desserts
yeah they have alcohol and they try and
make it like they add it to stuff and
I'm like no
like what like like ice cream and stuff
yeah ice cream it's like are you a fan
of the red bean paste to begin with
sometimes I've had it it's pretty good
but I'm rarely like super hyped about it
because I feel like it's just because
Japan just didn't have sugar for a long
time so they were like let's just use
this
like just admit it Japan like you didn't
have sugar and this is what you'd make
this is your dessert yeah but I mean
it's good
I'm convinced they have a bean Surplus
and they're trying to get rid of it oh
yeah of course that's why we figured out
70 million ways to use the soybean yeah
that's that's true actually they put soy
with everything yeah soybeans we've
literally figured out every combination
possible to use on a soybean you put it
in the garbage for a week you're like oh
[__] I can't eat wait a minute oh it's
not so oh okay yeah okay
yeah there's got to be some stuff I'm
not a fan of red bean paste either I
don't know I don't know if you have to
like grow up with it do you think we'd
like chocolate so much because we grew
up with it or is it just actually that
Opie
[Music]
one thing I've not like chocolate
covered strawberries and stuff uh yeah
it makes strawberries a lot better yeah
hell yes
yeah oranges
I mean if he can make you like oranges
that's uh
the only way that orange is edible yeah
there's actually one thing I don't like
which a lot of people do like
um salted chocolate never been a fan
really I don't know yeah never been a
fan same thing with chocolate with chili
chocolate as well I don't like chili
chocolate chili chocolate I don't I
don't understand I don't get chili
chocolate why people do that no uh I'm
Thai I love
spicy chitty stuff yeah get that [__]
out of my desserts I've never understood
chili chocolate yeah what are you gonna
say corner I like chili chocolate what
what do you like about it because what I
don't like about it is the fact that
it's like I like you know I like some
spice in my food and I like sweetness
but like spice and sweetness is couldn't
be further from the opposite in terms of
pallets it's like a almost like a
forbidden it's like I think that's what
makes you kind of nice it's a little bit
forbidden would you say it's a little
bit deviously I'm feeling a little bit
devious and naughty combine these two
flavors
I have the same opinion about chili
chocolate as whenever I see a shot and I
look at like the ingredients of the
shots and it has Tabasco sauce in it and
I'm like yeah and I'm just like oh [__]
get Get Bloody Mary's away from you I do
not understand Bloody Mary's dude I went
out last night and they ordered a bloody
mary the person I was with and this look
at this [__] thing let me show you
I'll try and show the camera dude you
know what's kind of weird I I've never
really liked a bloody mary but for some
reason oh my God same with a whole stick
of celery it's a whole stick of celery
that's not the wildest [__] I've seen I
just I mean you freaking can't see this
but I mean like yeah that Ash just came
with the whole thing
Australians really like Bloody Marys and
I don't know why it's because it's the
drink of Alcoholics all of my
associations how alcoholic it's like the
smoothie for alcohol it's The Hangover
alcohol drink you know I'm detoxing I'll
have a tomato drink this time I I don't
get it because it's you're just eating a
meal you know it feels it feels like a
meal and uh like the wildest [__] is the
uh I got one after after I get it the
last [__] I've seen is like the Bloody
Marys in whisk in Wisconsin which I
think is like more unhealthy than most
meals uh because I I swear to go like we
went to this bar and Sydney Sydney's mum
uh Sydney's mom and Sydney loves Bloody
Mary's but only from Wisconsin and I
remember I go into this bar and they
order a bloody Mary and I'm used to like
Bloody Marys having some witch and then
like a celery or something
um I swear to God this wasn't like a
cocktail it was it was just they took
like a meal and they'd like processed it
put this just put it in this drink and
then out of this drink they had a burger
on a stick and some wings that they that
they had put in this drink and served it
I [__] you not what the [__] okay they
put a burger on a stick and then stuck
it in the Bloody Mary and I'm like this
this is too far this has gone too far
how much is that Bloody Mary is it like
20 bucks yeah I think it's about 15 20
bucks to uh at the bars in Wisconsin
they will do anything they can to not
eat their vegetables
I'm sorry but like a lot of the time
they'll have something healthy or the
guys have healthy and they'll just find
10 other ways to make it unhealthy yeah
um I don't like honey on pizza
I'm not a fan I like honey on cheese
pizza I don't agree yeah I think it's
Abomination see I I didn't I'm of the
same opinion as a pineapple and pizza
yes get sweet stuff off of my yeah I
agree pineapple and pizza too is the
ultimate does not work combo okay to
stop trying to make it what about
pineapple in a burger
I'm still not I don't know why you can
how I can do all they want I'm not I'm
not bad I'm I'm not sold but it's not as
bad as pineapple and pizza for me what
about like sweet and sour pork that has
pineapple in it the sweet sour pork is
pineapple right the pork should be the
sweet and sour right I don't even know I
don't need a pineapple to do it like I
don't want that I don't want that watery
bite that the pineapple gives and I know
they fry it sometimes yeah but at that
point I'm like why are we even using the
pineapple let me just find something
else it's like putting oranges in my
salad you know I hate oranges inside I
know you I know you hate it because you
hate oranges I [__] love oranges but
just get that [__] out of myself any
fruit in my salad you don't like apples
only put apples in my salad I'm like
[__] this is like I've had so much one
percent thing I've ever said
um yeah but yeah I I that's yeah some
combinations